for today's classic interview we're
going back to something that we're
seeing less of now since the Supreme
Court's decision on same-sex marriage
bans at the state level this is my
interview with James White a sort of a
quirky anti-gay pastor who also told
some interesting stories about his wife
I don't think it needs much more of an
introduction let's jump right into it
I'm joined today by James White he is a
current you CC pastor and he is located
in the gold free Oklahoma Church so
let's start first James what is the UCC
what denomination is that the United
Church of Christ is a combination of the
merger took place in the early 60s
between the evangelical reformed sure
the Congregational Christian Church
there very little and our partners so to
speak with the disciples of Christ
you're ordained to one you can be a
minister in the other and vice versa it
seems here lately a lot of the church
growth has come because of MCC churches
that left the Metropolitan Community
Church and join the UCC but ok so what
ya got let that think it tells us what
it is but I don't I want to get right
into kind of your situations so you're
going to be stepping down as pastor of
the goal tree Oklahoma UCC Church and
the issue you have a problem with is
same-sex marriage so outline what is the
church's position and what is your
position that is so different that it's
causing you to resign well actually it's
a local level they agree with me but the
problem is that they don't want to leave
the denomination they're great people
but so I think let's so let me reframe
it because I want to walk people through
it churches in the UCC recognize and
consolidate
sex marriage and that's what you
disagree with right I just want to be
totally explicit so our audience might
over top so absolutely I first became a
part of the UCC back in 2008
and was driving down to Oklahoma City I
was actually a part of a church that's
mostly gay and lesbian for a while and
then once I graduated seminary I had to
find a preaching position but the more I
the more I personal study I did on my
own the more I realized that what I was
what I had been taught in seminary and
what I learned through the denomination
wasn't accurate so explain that so what
what is your view of same-sex marriage I
I define marriage between a man or woman
that comes from the Bible what I've
discovered over dealing with people in
the denomination is that the more that
they value experience over scripture the
more liberal they are and the more that
they value the Bible over experience
then the more conservative they tend to
be now as someone who has studied this
and is a student of knowledge so to
speak
wouldn't it tell you that if people base
their lives and their points of views
more on their experience and their
thinking than on what a book purportedly
written by God tells them maybe that's
more what we should be listening to
maybe experience and logic tell us more
about how we should treat gay and
lesbian couples than a book clearly
written by humans but supposedly written
by God tells us maybe maybe we could
learn from that well let me make one
thing clear and this is probably where
some conservatives would disagree with
me on is that I don't think of this as
being in salvation I think there are
people who are gay and lesbian who are
genuinely saved that's who I will see on
who I will see on the other side okay
and in the thing about like my
experience with cathedrals hope is that
these people are genuinely wanting to do
the right thing they do reach out to
people at the gay pride event and there
are thousands of people there
and it was really disheartening you know
as like the Sunday night service after
that weekend would take place and you
might have three or four new people show
up when you literally handed out
thousands of Flyers and buttons and you
had people participate in this parade
either on Friday or Saturday and then
very few people showed up so yeah that
came on tough but the salvation of the
people of Cathedral Hope at all yeah and
I'm not either but but Salvation aside
just for a second it sounds like your
opposition to gay marriage lesbian
marriage is primarily Bible based in
other words you didn't mention one
anti-gay argument which is it's not
natural
you didn't mention the it doesn't lead
to reproduction you didn't mention well
it's a legal redefinition and I don't
like that correct me if I'm wrong but
your opposition is mostly Bible based is
that right well I would say that and
here's the thing that really kind of
threw a red flag up for me is that a lot
of the people I spoke with that are gay
and lesbian whenever I would mention
things like bigamy polygamy and other
things they never really wanted to draw
the line there they never really want to
say well that stuff is bad what I'm
hearing now is the idea of marriage
equality for everybody will have to have
some kind of limits because if you don't
then then then what are you defining
marriage and well that's interesting
because and again you and I are talking
we're not having a legal discussion
obviously religious texts have no
bearing at all on on legal structure in
this country whether you agree with that
or not with me we're leaving that out
for this conversation but let's address
it from the point of view of the Bible
the Bible talks about men with multiple
wives men with multiple wives and
concubines etc etc so is it not
arbitrary to say that because of the
Bible you are against gay marriage for
example although the Bible talks about
multiple wives concubines etc talks
about stoning your your wife if she's
not a virgin on on the wedding day etc
right isn't it all just kind of
cherry-picking
well the thing about that is I'm glad
you brought it up is that you really
can't find one example of a healthy
relationship where where somebody did
have multiple wives I think the Bible
mentions in 1st Corinthians that we have
the old test as an example for us and
really if you think about it could you
really have two three four wives and
love each one of them equally and the
same I don't think you can so let's use
that guy like that I like that you're
applying that question which is let's
just think about this logically and say
can you really be married to four people
and love them equally and have that type
of relationship and you're thinking the
answer is no what is it about a
relationship between one man and one
woman
I'm sorry between two men or between two
women where you couldn't have the same
type of love that you have in a
male-female relationship applying just
the kind of casual logic test that you
apply just a second ago
well to add some further to the design
of marriage I think the thing that makes
marriage so great is that you're you're
married to somebody who thinks
differently you need to buy it
during the last 13 plus years my wife
has challenged me he stretched me really
your wife and I will rech to you I would
say well just when I was when I first
got married I was very selfish and very
self-centered and I did not even realize
how much so during the time we've been
married I've learned how to care for
others in a way that you know boy James
what you're dealing what you're saying
James if I may you're going down an
incredibly misogynistic path which is
suggesting that only women can teach men
how to care for others you're also using
very anecdotal evidence which as a
student to who someone who is an
educated person I'm sure you know that
anecdotal evidence is not really what we
should talk about to discuss broad
policy or or ideas it seems incredibly
offensive to so many men to say that
women are what is needed to learn to
care about others well I think it goes
two ways I think there are things
she's learned about life for me as well
that I'm contrasting that to two men or
two women because in least in my opinion
it's a mirror image you're you're with
somebody who does think like you do and
isn't really going to challenge you on
certain things I just think that this is
a very silly argument though James
because the idea that you think the same
as anyone else who is the same gender as
you and therefore you wouldn't learn
from from marriage I've honestly it's an
interest it's I'm interested in this
idea because I've never heard it before
but it's not a very strong argument is
it well we'll have to agree to disagree
on that one uh I know me personally my
life is very fulfilling good ah and now
if you were attracted to men if you were
born just being attracted to men would
you not be fulfilled if you were able to
marry the man that you loved
hypothetically right would you would you
not find fulfillment in that hmm that's
an interesting question I probably
honestly I don't know I've - I'm - so
hard for you to imagine not being
straight because you were born straight
correct um yeah I'm not going to
completely dismiss the science that's I
think you're referring to but I think
there needs to be more done as far as
whether or not you can be born okay I
think there needs to be more scientific
research I'm also Michael my question is
what did I guess say did you ever decide
James you when you were I don't know
seven to say okay well right now I'm
completely neutral between being
attracted to men or women I think I'm
going to choose to be attracted to women
you never had that revelation did you
well most of my time up until the age of
ten I was either playing basketball
football or kickball so that's fair
perfectly fair so what ten is when is
that one you made the decision you could
have gone either way
you could have been into guys you could
have been into girls and you said well
I'm ten I played enough kickball now I'm
going to choose to be into women is that
it went for you or did you at some point
just realize you're attracted to women
that's an interesting question who's the
actual girl I was attracted to probably
sixth grade I knew a girl named Shannon
who had failed their grade and so she
was a little bit more jealous a
physically mature than some adults and
uh so you were attracted you were
attracted to your classmates breasts and
that was a that was a physical reaction
you had you never said I'm going to
decide today to like my classmates
breasts that just happened okay I think
I see that you're kind of putting up
some obstacles but I think the audience
kind of gets where I'm going with this
we are at a time James I wish you the
best of luck I'm sorry that your
opposition to marriage equality is
leaving you to leave your position I
hope you find a new position and I do
thank you for joining us thank you so
much ever great day